[music]
We're going to keep this uh panel
conversational, but maybe to kick us
off, do each of you maybe want to talk
about your business for and yourself for
20 seconds so that the audience know uh
who we're talking to.
>> Yeah, happy to and excited to be here.
Uh I'm Ani Kelkar. I'm a partner with
McKenzie from our Boston office. I
globally lead McKenzie's robotics and
physical AI efforts which gives me the
privilege of serving the ecosystem from
investors to technology builders to
pertinent to this conversation a lot of
the end users who will adopt robotics.
>> Hi uh I'm K uh from Tron KKK Japan. So
we are working as some system integrator
of physical AI and technology
distributor. So we distribute cutting
edge uh physical AI technology from all
over the world into Japan and we are
working to realize their manufacturing
physical application with the Japanese
enterprise uh customers mainly
automotives.
Thank you very much.
>> Yeah. Hello. Good afternoon. My name is
Roger Roger Joe. I'm representing this
AGI bot company here in France uh with
uh double targets. The first target is
to develop the market around our
solutions which is mostly in the
humanoid robots and second one is to
build active ecosystem here in France.
Yeah, glad to meet you all.
>> Hi everyone, my name is Yan Yan Rudat.
I'm the chief growth and revenue officer
with Humanoid. That means I run the
commercial parts of the company and also
the partnership elements. Have more of
an automotive background. Was an early
employee with Tesla. Scaled the business
from zero to the first billionaire and
hope to do the same now in this new tech
space.
>> Amazing. What a great panel. Anie, I'm
going to start with you. Um, robotics
and humanoids has attracted billions of
dollars is of investment. what separates
uh the successful companies from the
ones that won't be here in a couple of
years.
>> I I think there is a fundamental sort of
market making motion that's underway
right now. um which is companies are
trying to discover applications that
make the durable market. the market that
has a return on investment that leads to
a fleet of robots being deployed whether
it's a manufacturing site or a logistics
site while at the same time trying to
generate revenue in the near term from
this developer market where a lot of
people are still purchasing robots
largely in entertainment applications or
research applications and so I think the
successful companies will have the right
portfolio mix between creating
applications that are more enduring
things like you see with Boston Dynamics
with the inspection application. You saw
with DJI bot with sort of their pick and
place applications, things that are
adding value to customers today while
keeping a road map to much more
complicated tasks in much more
unstructured environments but not
jumping the gun too early.
So maybe to the panel, each of you sit
in a different part of the value chain.
What does it mean to build a flourishing
business in your part of the business?
Yan, why don't you start us off?
So I would say we have a different
approach. Um what we do is more some
sort of business transformation um with
companies. So we're not uh leading
through classic uh automation, pricing,
costbook, etc. conversations. It starts
maybe more higher up in the organization
with thought leaders and and chiefs and
discussing more the educational part and
the consulting part you know um with
them about what for example it could
mean to have a third shift without
hiring people you know or whether they
have like a certain uh strategy around
dark factory. So, and from there um then
I mean lead the uh conversation more
towards the actual product and what it
could mean for them. But it's definitely
more centered around business
transformation elements and consulting
around that.
>> Yeah, we noticed that at Boston Dynamics
also that when you don't prepare the
organization for what's about to happen,
it often fails, right? Um so in the end
we ended up putting posters up and
telling people, hey, there's robots that
are that are coming. So I think you're
right successful implementation will
require business transformation as well.
Maybe just to add I think we we had
surveyed u executives across different
verticals around why they had not
automated at scale and just to give
people dimension only 6% of factories in
North America have any robotics at scale
and just in last year you know China is
now installing 10 times as many
industrial robots than the US and um
when you ask executives the largest uh
respondents or largest share of
respondents come back with, well, the
business case was quite narrow, right?
You had to like squint your eye. You had
to think about the business cases. This
is a longerterm investment. This isn't
going to be a 2-year payback period. The
second biggest one was the internal
capabilities and change management. It
was we did a first P. It was great.
People got excited about it. Then the
spotlight shifted. The robot broke. We
didn't know what to do with it. We
didn't know what, you know, how to tell
the operations manager, hey, you're
living with this. We're here to help
you. We'll make sure the robot is up and
running. And so, a lot of these PC's
start becoming monuments rather than
proof points that the technology works.
>> Yeah. Roger, obviously you're in charge
of France for Agi bot, but um when you
hear stories from from China, is it
similar there or is it much faster in
terms of adoption and um business
transformation?
>> I think there are uh clearly certain
similarities. I think in the two nation
we are pmatic people, right? uh we do uh
step by step to trial it to get a P done
and to scale up to get a measurable
payback the ROI and before you know
deploying uh large scale. Uh however in
China the difference is we compete on
speed. Yeah. We want to deliver as many
as humanoid units to different scenarios
uh to have real feedback from the dehan
from the field and to realeimont to
refeed you know the the loop to improve
uh here in Europe. My feeling is uh uh
we need to you know look into uh the
compliance the regulation which we took
very seriously as a feature uh of the
product. I can give you an example.
Before we shipping out even the first
piece in Europe, we anticipate a lot of
certifications including the C
certification. We have people looking
into the GTPR uh data role uh machinery
safety directives to make sure that it
plays in our favor. It is a feature not
a barrier. And then step by step I think
uh we're going to see uh as in China for
the past six or 12 months uh different P
in the real field. Yeah.
>> Yeah. I hear that from so many robotics
companies that you go to America the
first question is what's the ROI going
to look like? And in America and you
come to Europe and they want to talk
about the CE certification and some
government regulation and their workers
council. So it it seems like the scale
of adoption in Europe will be slower
because of that and one wonders as a
European I find that sort of scary.
Uh if you do the comparison it seems
slow but I think we are moving steadily
forward. Uh at this moment we are not
chasing the speed. Yeah I think we are
preparing the future uh even by taking
you know small steps as Ali just
mentioned. Yeah, we are not going to
take you know a moonshot. The humanoid
is not a magic trick that solves all
kind of issues in the factory. We need
to be specific to find those use case
where uh if you compare the investment
and the return on investment is pretty
much reasonable and also the uh cost of
trying of saying yes is reasonably uh
low. That's where we need to put our
effort so that we can, you know, nurture
the market within the next coming
quarters and preparing the future.
>> Kai, your company combines humanoid
robotics with digital twins. Why combine
the two and not sell them separately?
What's the benefit? Uh yes, uh the Japan
is the same situation. So if we want to
bring the human robot in action in the
factory, the many people against about
it. What is the ROI? What is the safety?
Do do you want to stop their production
line? So, but if we cannot try anything,
we cannot find any use case.
So, then our digital twin is one of the
key future. So, if we can utilize the
digital twin, we can make data
correction and model development and
testing. So, we can do the quick
iteration in the simulation. Then our
customer can move into the real action.
So this is a really uh important the
thing especially for very let's say the
slow uh company like Japan. Yes. So this
is a reason why we sell the human and
robot and digital team simulation
solution together.
>> So they can derisk the deployments in
the simulation first and then launch it.
>> Uh yes it depend on the case. So the
shimulation uh the P on the simulation
is just P. So but the many people want
to do what will happen in the factory
floor. But ultimately if we think
[snorts] or to deploy as many as tasks
with a humanoid we cannot do every task
in real robot with a real robot that
time we must need digital twin
simulation in advance.
Y that sort of ties back into you talked
about business transformation as one of
the cores of how you go to market.
What how does that manifest itself in
how you sell and how you measure
success? Um maybe let's start with the
alternative classic capex purchase or
sell. So if you do that then you
obviously talk to a procurement manager
you know you have your price book um and
you talk specifications and then you're
measured down to the cost right and this
is a um yeah race [clears throat] to the
bottom basically so that's why we came
up with the uh business transformation
narrative um because also the companies
they need more education and and
consulting around that as mentioned
before um but everything which follows
then changes as well a bit um the
adoption in order to make that easier on
the price points. For example, there is
a monthly subscription robot as a
service as we call it a turnkey solution
where everything is in including the
training and tailor operation service
for example um for clients. So, so
everything which follows then also
changes and on your question about the
matrix. Yes, throughput speed is part of
that conversation like with other
automation solutions but it goes beyond
that given humanoids can be much more
flexible. They can do a use case in the
morning and it's something different in
the afternoon or a third use case or
whatnot. So we discuss also elements
like the redeployment times and
integration in new environments and so
it's more holistically um yeah also um
derived from the flexibility the
solution offers.
>> So all your customers are on a
subscription so nobody buys the humanoid
robots they they are on a subscription
basis.
>> Yeah at the moment definitely. Um we're
thinking about maybe changing that uh
and at the right time let's say uh maybe
the right time is also when system
integrators etc come into the game but
right now it's uh um everything is
discussed in the robot as a service
subscription part yeah
>> that's different for argot roger right
you guys sell robots or you do both
[clears throat]
>> yeah in fact we have a different uh
business tracks we sell of course
hardware and we do data business also uh
thanks to the massive production uh
capability we have delivered 1,000 piece
of humanoid robots in our data
collection center constantly working on
the real world tasks and we open sourced
also one good sample through the brand
of AG bot world under hugging face uh
the third one is also as you have
mentioned we have this um RAS business
also yeah robot as a service and
mentioned in order to enable customer to
decide launching a pock uh the RAS model
is clearly also a way to lower down the
capex in the beginning. Yeah. So anid we
hear so many different ways to go to
market. We we've heard so many different
applications throughout the day for
humanoid robots. Um what brings positive
ROI and what are you seeing from your
clients? Yeah, it's a it's a very hard
question because I think a lot of the
ROI conversation today is very context
specific. Um I think most of the ROI
conversation today is constrained by
capabilities of the robots. What can you
actually perform in a production context
reliably at the throughput at the
quality level required? And within the
current sort of capability domains of
robots, you're seeing a lot of visual
inspection tasks meet that metric. But
visual inspection is valuable only in
certain contexts where asset uptime is
extremely valuable and it's often a
situation like a refinery or a you know
chemicals plant where the operator is
sitting in the operator's room is doing
multiple tasks during the day and isn't
the highest ROI for the operator to walk
around and inspect you know pumps and
compressors and others. I think that's
that's one use case that is coming up. I
think a second use case that is coming
up is missions around um inspection
related to maintenance, but these are
lighter inspections. This this isn't
necessarily someone, you know, repairing
an entire engine that is broken down.
This could be someone going in, you
know, pressing a few buttons, turning a
new fan on. Those types of tasks in
unstructured environments are seeing
ROI. And then in the factory setting, a
lot of the automation tasks that
humanoids are being deployed in are not
necessarily the hardest bottleneck tasks
in the production line. To Kai's point,
no one's going to be willing to have the
line stop because a humanoid robot made
a mistake. A lot of these tasks are
where a full standard fixed robot
solution would not make sense. But the
skill required of the robot is simple.
And so the flexibility of the robot is
what makes the ROI work where if
something changes you can always go back
to a manual line. These are largely sort
of tending tasks whether it is machine
tending tool tending kitting. Um those
also seem to have ROI again when priced
appropriately at the right business
model.
Roger I want to come back to you. Uh
Agiot went rapidly from starting the
company to mass production. What did you
have to believe and what did your
customers have to believe to go from
from very early to mass production so
quickly?
[clears throat]
>> Uh yeah I think um we definitely qualify
the description moving fastly. Yeah,
just to give you a figure that uh after
one year of the creation of the company
in beginning of 2024 uh we started our
first factory one year after 10,000
piece in January 2025 until end of June
this year we delivered 15,000 units of
humanoid robots. I think um the secret
lies into that is um um the
repeatability and the reliability. Uh
because we can all have one robot, you
know, working uh in on the stage impress
people once or in a demo showroom. Uh
yeah, demonstrate a wellprepared
showcase. But here we set the bar at
really um uh more flexible environment
with a a big uh important variety of
different missions uh with a certain uh
you know uh suplex so flex flexibility
capable of uh handling different
missions well maintained reliability
that's where we you know start to say
okay we are ready from you know uh small
quantity of production to mass
production.
Yeah, it's super impressive. Um, you're
amongst friends here and we won't tell
anybody, but tell us what broke first.
What broke first when you went from zero
to 15,000?
Uh, I understand that question as what
would be the challenging part? Um, I
would say uh the supply chain and the
quality control. uh the supply chain
because uh in China if you do the
counting I think there are at least
maybe 150 50 companies or even close to
200 launching themsel into the humanoid
robots industry. Uh we are not queuing
as them uh in front of the different
suppliers. We do in-house design for
most of the important hardware
components such as uh you know the
joints, actuators, reducers, sensors,
lighter etc etc. So that makes us you
know uh the owner of our own um how say
quality control mechanism and the road
map of our products. So I think that's
uh that was a challenging part and
that's how we deal with that challenge
and of course the quality control when
you scale from a 10 piece where uh
hidden uh flaw would be you know
invisible and not impacting that much
when you deliver 10,000 pieces. Yeah. If
you do not do a high quality high
standard quality control in your factory
I think the problem will you know you
will be how say enon day um how to say
the word in day
drawn you'll be drawn in all the quality
issues after that
um yan you spent a decade with Tesla as
EVs were ramping up what are the biggest
learnings uh from that scale to the
robotics industry.
>> Well, I would say there are a lot of
things you can compare. Um, for example,
the adoption curve. I think when I
remember about 10 years back, obviously
you had the early adopters, the
pioneers, right? But also like the
skeptical people and that's something I
see here as well, right? Um you have
companies now with a humanoid strategy
already in place you know doing tenders
or how big they are that's questionable
but they're they're um in this space and
others you know who do not have even
like a plan about uh implementing
anything. So the adoption is definitely
one part um goes a bit to to his point.
So the whole vertical integration um it
was the same 10 years back right there
was no battery pack for automotive right
uh today you go to a CL or to anyone and
you have like performance battery packs
or more um you know range and charging
capabilities and whatnot and this is
something we see as well that's why we
are full stack company um founded two
years ago there was not a lot in this
space right so you have to you know go
down a different path and invent
yourself right So there are a lot of um
similarities here. Things which are
obviously completely different is uh
consumer brand is is differently led and
built and and through you know the
celebrities back in the days and whatn
not but here we're discussing a bit more
complex uh B2B sales cycles and and
conversations. So there's a different
different industry obviously we're
tackling.
>> Yeah. Why don't we have celebrities yet
in Right. We need we need more
celebrities. Um Kai talk to us a little
bit about in Japan the manufacturing
culture is so very different. What does
it take to be successful in a in a
Japanese environment and what what's
different?
>> Okay. So if we talk uh with the customer
I found the customer has customer
misunderstand
someone bring the solution with uh
challengings. So which means the
customer expect hey what should we do
with a human robot? Customer expect
someone tell the killer use case and the
killer scenario
[laughter]
>> the room is literally falling apart like
but for the human robot so the most
advantage of the human robot is a
flexibility. So if we do the only the
pick and place we just do that with a uh
industry robot. So if we think about the
flexible multiple task scenario the only
the user can comes up with the use case
and the scenario but user doesn't think
about it because you user doesn't know
about the technology trend. So uh this
is the biggest the hurdle to deploy the
human robot in the factory. So to s to
be successful in the human robot uh
industry the most important thing right
now is to find killer use case but this
killer use case this knowledge only come
from the users and the data as well. So
important thing is to let's say enlight
this truth to the customer and cooperate
with the users to generate data and use
case. So
I think it's amazing that you're
building an integration company for
these modern robots because it's
definitely needed because there aren't
the existing integration companies uh
are not ready to do this yet. But how do
you structure partnerships with uh
innovators um so that they see you as a
partner of success when when they want
to go to market?
>> Um yes. So the evolution of the physical
AI is so quick so rapid. So there is no
room to compete do the small compete by
reinventing their wheel. So I keep
telling about this and try to combine
the every technology together. So this
kind of their explanation is very
important to make the person sip the
right partnip.
>> Spinning the topic wheel a little bit.
Anie, um,
so many new entrance into the market.
Uh, as, uh, um, as Roger said, there's
probably 200 in China, there's probably
20 in Europe, 20 in in the US.
You're starting a company. What should
you focus on in the first 18 months to
make sure that you're setting up a
foundation for success? Yeah, I think
this is a very expensive market to try
and be a meto competitor where you are
trying to do exactly what someone else
has already built because that someone
else has not scaled yet. So the person
you're trying to copy is also sharpening
their playbook trying to discover the
applications. So doing the same is a
fool's errand because you're just behind
on the learning curve. I think the key
thing here is to find a differentiated
value proposition while sticking to some
of the principles that the incumbents
have laid out. And the differentiated
value proposition might be a difference
in sort of vertical that you target. It
might be your focus more less on
industrials and more on services or
consumer robotics. It might be to take a
differentiated approach with how
training and sort of you know data is
run out. But again keeping the
principles in mind that we heard which
is you want to control your destiny as
much as possible. You want to keep the
customer sort of value in focus because
after the first uh you know showcase you
will need to answer questions whether
it's the CEO or the plant manager on
what the long-term roadmap for value
creation is. So keeping those principles
constant but finding something that is
truly an unmet need in the market I
think is increasingly important.
So with the last couple of seconds uh
left, I'm sure the audience has heard so
much today. So everybody's getting
overwhelmed uh with with input. Give me
the 30 secondond elevator pitch for each
of your companies. So what should the
audience remember about um about your
company? Y want to start us off?
>> So um on Nani's point, I like what you
said. You need a differentiator. So
we're not like a broad humanoid company.
We are more what entropy is for AI
meaning having an um industry focus.
That's exactly what we're doing with the
business transformation partner coming
in solving your specific use cases in
the space and we only leave once that is
done. Right? This is our pitch.
>> Roger. For me I think uh we
differentiate compared to others with a
full portfolio with our data capability
continuous innovation and here the
message to the audience is uh nobody can
afford and turning their head around to
to not looking at the humanoid. So we
think uh if you look uh harder enough we
will find the killer use case as Kai
mentioned where we can find a concrete
payback. If the uh feedback on the
payback is reasonable uh starting from
that day I think everything will became
much more real.
>> Yes. So um the message is we need more
invest effort and money for user side.
So for the vendor site there is a many
genius right here and there is a many
investors but for user side only the
user can create the kira use case. So we
have to invest much much more to find uh
kira use case to users. So this is my
message today.
>> Yeah and I think building on what guy
said I think the long-term potential of
humanoids and advanced robots is really
high. the near-term path is quite
uncertain and that's really where you
know McKenzie has played a role with the
end users to try and help them cut
through the hype cut through the noise
and think about what their road map
needs to be and then for the ecosystem
to learn from the mistakes of the EV and
solar buildout and maybe this time do it
much more cost- effectively and for
investors as well there is multiple
billions of dollar rounds that are being
raised some of those are going to pay
back heavily most of those won't so
that's that's kind 12.
>> Thank you everyone.
>> Thank you.